the jurgen experience there is a
kind of a third kind of secret there is
a secret
sauce in this whole mix and this is kind
of what brought me to some my lab
you know we do work with typical people
but we also and do some work with people
from
david's former community and domestic
and foreign special operations who are
interested in this process for obvious
reasons
how can you leverage the nervous system
to build better
longer lasting warriors it's a really
interesting question
and you could do that with brain machine
interface you could do that with
um you can imagine doing that with drugs
or with you know supplementation or
nutrition all of that
but since the nervous system sits at the
foundation of
any of those we start to think about
this problem and
there's actually another element to it
which is the reward pathways involving
dopamine
so you asked about kids like why they
can learn all day long
so their brain is very different but it
still needs some degree of focus and
they still need to get their sleep
they still have to obey those two rules
of this process
but they engage in something else which
is really powerful
which is play a lot of their learning is
through playful exchange especially with
the little kids like in kindergarten
nursery school
and then as they get older the social
dynamics can be kind of harsh but they
can also be really pleasurable and fun
so the molecule dopamine is a really
misunderstood molecule we all make it
from a
location in the back of our brain and
people think of it as like reward like
oh i
got a bunch of money or i you know did a
great performance dopamine is
responsible for that feeling of feeling
great but in addition
dopamine is what's released anytime an
animal or human
thinks it's on the right path and that's
very subjective
so this is not and i want to be really
clear that this is not
positive thinking or you know the secret
or telling yourself that you're
performing well even when you're not
right like if you're a rioter and you
break into a courthouse but you feel
like you're on the right path you're
going to get a release of dopamine heavy
rain even if you're yeah even if you're
committing a crime
and you really probably shouldn't be
doing that yeah mother nature built
these systems adrenaline acetylcholine
dopamine
to be very generic in terms of what can
activate on purpose
you know cocaine will cause a tremendous
release of dopamine so will
methamphetamine
the problem is it sets a focus on just
getting more of that thing
right so dopamine is evoked through
play it's evoked through humor
right if you've ever just been working
like mad or you see this in
you know team guys know this really well
that you know because they tell me
that you can be in the worst situation
and somebody will crack a joke
and all of a sudden it's like you have
energy
now that couldn't have been glycogen
that wasn't because you're ketogenic it
wasn't because you're whatever
that's neural energy and that neural
energy is dopamine
is that what happens when you hear a
great song and you get pumped up
is that the same thing absolutely and
the reason dopamine is so powerful in
this process
of neural plasticity is that dopamine
has the ability to
buffer noradrenaline so that stress that
you feel when you're in
effort it's very hard for most people to
keep that going
but when you get a and when i say a shot
i mean internal release of dopamine
through humor or through the sense that
you're on the right path let's take the
fight example
where it's stressful and you're getting
beaten down all of a sudden you land one
or you do something properly and the
other guy starts to timber a little bit
or
shuffle a little bit you gain a chemical
advantage
and it comes in two forms one is it
triggers marking of the synapses that
likely will change later we rarely
forget the events associated with
dopamine
for that reason because they signal oh
whatever's happening now that was good
and in addition to that they start
pushing back on the level of
acetylcholine
excuse me noradrenaline in the brain
stem and this is crucial
because there was a study that came out
two years ago
not from my group that asked why do we
quit
you know if you set you know 800 or even
500 pounds on the bar out there i can't
lift it
so i'm not talking about that kind of
quitting i'm talking about a long run
why do i quit if i'm not injured
like what actually causes quitting when
do when do we decide that something is
futile
and it turns out that for every bit of
effort any bit of ever lifting a glass
of water or running up a hill
or in a fight they're little bits of us
of noradrenaline adrenaline that are
released in the brain and body and
there's a counter
there's a cell type which are called
glia which literally means glue in latin
these cells are paying attention
to how much norepinephrine is coming and
if it hits a certain threshold
the brain stops voluntary control over
the musculature says that's it i quit
and there are these beautiful
experiments where they manipulate the
visual environment
so that this isn't they're certain that
this isn't lack of
muscle fuel this or liver fuel this is
lack of
neural fuel dopamine pushes back that
level of noradrenaline
and it gives you more gas it lets you go
further
and you see this through teamwork when
you feel like you're supported when
you're
in cohesion humor play
if you know if you're in serious effort
and it's just things are going terribly
maybe
i've never done comedy but you're trying
to write a joke and it's just
frustrating and then suddenly you just
kind of laugh at how ridiculous the
process is
there's a kind of loosening or a
lightning and you have more
energy that energy is reductions in
epinephrine
[Applause]